en sibérie dans le nord de la russie des
pompes à tête de cheval c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle ex très lentement du
pétrole pas seulement pour consolation
locale les hydrocarbures pétrole et gaz
représentent 60% des exportations du
pays
c'est un peu l'alberta la russie adamo
ce nouveau poster nationales héctor
fedosenko sens dès que les choses
commencent à ralentir sa compagnie de
forage pose de moins en moins deux
piliers pour soutenir de nouvelles
constructions
il se plaint que les gens s'empressent
de dépenser leurs roubles pour acheter
n'importe quoi avant que leurs monnaies
perdre encore plus de sa valeur des
chutes des prix du pétrole la russie en
a connues notamment en 2008 les il n'y
avait pas ce contexte de guerre en
ukraine de sanctions eu de tensions avec
l'europe et d'amérique du nord
en 2008 on s'était bien promis de
restructurer tout le secteur industriel
russe pour dépendre moins deep et pas le
moins de l'étranger pour produire plus
localement et être plus autonome
sergueï markov dirige l'institut
d'études politiques de moscou il était
un proche de vladimir poutine
il avoue que la réforme est juste riel
n'avait pas été prise au sérieux et ce
mot à dire
zen stone économiques internes non it et
comme un éclair absolute l'inévitable
lindsey industries industries industries
street ait subie ces dernières années il
ya eu des efforts de modernisation
industrielle notamment en coopération
avec l'europe
et ensuite igor iourguens président de
l'institut de développement contemporain
de russie s'en féliciter mais maintenant
les choses changent il faut éviter sur
la dépendance de pétrole mais en même
temps il faut investir beaucoup ce tout
nouvel technologique est sous sanction
est sans argent qui provient des marchés
international finance
donc c'est vachement plus difficile tout
est foutu ramenant à cause de l'ukraine
à cause de la guerre à cause du social
pour l'instant le russe moyen ne ressent
pas encore l'impact de tous ces
problèmes économiques mais au fur et à
mesure qu'on aura du mal à trouver des
produits importés de la nourriture
jusqu'aux pièces de machinerie la
population sera davantage prête à des
changements le problème en fait
fondamental d'un des princes
fondamentaux de l'économie russe sait
que la rente pétrolière ou des
hydrocarbures en général est telle qu'en
fait il vaut mieux importer que de
produire sur place
or avec la baisse du rouble on se
retrouve avec
dans l'obligation en fait de produire
sur place on va réduire les importations
et essayer de produire local où tout
dépend de la manière dont le
gouvernement russe va diriger manager
cette crise est ce que cette crise aux
multiples facettes peut en venir à
servir de moteur au renouveau de la
production industrielle en russie
les pressions sont plus fortes que
jamais plus la russie voudra rivaliser
entrer en compétition avec l'occident
plus elle devra être autonome et si
l'amour c'est pierre radio canada à
moscou